(whoosh)
(soft boom)
- [Evan] I believe in pink.
I believe that laughing is
the best calorie burner.
I believe in kissing.
Kissing a lot.
"I believe in being strong
"when everything seems to be going wrong.
"I believe that happy girls
are the prettiest girls.
"I believe that tomorrow is another day
"and I believe in miracles."
Audrey Hepburn.
One of the greatest screen
actresses of all time.
If you want to achieve success,
start with what makes you happy.
Before worrying about
what your one word is,
think about everything
that makes you happy.
Start by making a list.
Just write what comes to mind
and don't worry yet
about where it leads you.
Get lost in happiness
as you make your list.
Here are a few questions
to get you started.
What's your favorite movie?
What's your favorite book?
What's your favorite song?
Who is your best friend?
What is your favorite quote to live by?
What kind of people do
you like to hang out with?
Who was your favorite boss?
Why are you with your significant other?
Who was your favorite teacher?
What do you did you love
most about your parents?
What activities make you come alive?
What do you look forward
to most in your week?
When was the last time you
felt overwhelmingly happy?
These are all primers to get
you thinking and writing.
Answer these questions
and add whatever else comes
to mind that makes you happy.
Fill the page with happiness
and feel the energy that comes from it.
It could be the path to
your next million dollars.
(whoosh)
(boom)